[Music]
hello and welcome everyone today to the
session
my name is Misha Brooklyn I'm the
product manager for Google cloud
BigTable and today we're talking with
week a and outbound about their use
cases with big data processing with
Vic's able data flow and data Prague and
today to get us started we have Sean
medalie director of engineering at we
say thanks Bishop I'm charmed from B
pain before we get into understanding
how we paid bill takes a data pipeline I
want to tell more about we pay and what
the use case actually is so we are
talking about the fraud detection and we
pay adjusting to the CP to all of you
with a pro-x payment term services to
online platforms like for example if you
want to give money to somebody on
GoFundMe the actual payment engine
behind that is we pay so the specific
example here we are talking about these
FreshBooks so if you are a construction
kind of a company you want to send your
clients we noise you did some work so
the client gets invoice now they want to
get paid how do they get paid right so
that broken kind of experience is you
can ask the service provider to create
account another platform and the client
goes and pays for their it completely
makes tender when you start it's a
broken user experience so to fix these
things companies start to do what we
call integrated payments so it's in the
same slope they can actually send the
invoice and get paid but payments is
hard it's a very much a regulated space
there is compliance risk there is fraud
risk there is lots of other stuff
working with the parent partners the
Cardinal Network has certain rules and
so on right so it's a little bit hard so
we pay offers easy to use a px and
completely abstract away all the
operations difficulties the compliance
difficulties everything else so that's
what we paid does and these how we are
different there are some platforms them
providers in the market space where
they give you some user control user
experience control so you can actually
integrate into their into their flows
the second case is they offer risk
protection but none of them actually do
both giving you complete control of the
user experience as well as risk
protection so because we are taking the
risk that means our platform has to be
good so just to give a sense of like
what kind of risk that we have as
because we are a plus we are taking
payments from unknown party like a
merchant and we are paying out too we
have critical payments from the clients
and we are paying out to merchants there
could be fraud on both sides merchants
could be fraudulent the Bears could be
fraudulent and sometimes because of the
collusion fraud where somebody can play
on both sides of the fence an example
would be a bad person could create a
merchant account and have a bunch of
stolen credit cards and pay himself all
the money and then after a while the
real one of the state cars will Cena
cannot really wear this service provider
why am I getting this charger right so
they will charge back so the whole thing
will be unwound and then will try to
recoup from the merchants but merchants
is bad so it's already gone so we pay
because we offer the risk protection we
have to take the loss so the risk
management piece is very important for
us so because it is very important and
what let's look at like what makes a
risk platform great right so the fraud
fraudsters are always changing they are
changing the behavior that testing the
differences they are basically adapting
to the changes that we make it's not
like a one-time one directional move
like a chess we make a move they make in
right and but they are also leaking a
lot of data along the way they are
providing data to the transactions they
are providing data through like
environmental data what getting exact
details of it but there is a lot of data
that they leak in the kind of browsers
and all the things that they use they
also
there is also information in terms of
the vendor data like we can go to look
at like third-party vendors like a crate
bureaus and so on what information that
they had there is lot of data we should
be able to ingest this diverse piece of
data and learn from it so we cannot
directly throw in the raw data and
expect the models or rules to perform
them so we need to organize this data as
much as we can so that it becomes easy
and apparent for models and rules to
work all this data and then we need to
have greater automation we can't put all
of these things in front of human agents
to basically make too much too much
volume so you'd be it will be very much
cost prohibitive to put all of these
cases in front of the agents so what we
need is make a high precision kind of a
system that catches almost all the best
but only catches very few good people
that's what we want to build now to
enable this to cut the convert the raw
data from the numbers like the price or
the ABS response code which is the zip
number that keeps punching in at the gas
stations and so on so we can we can
augment this data further by adding
geolocation data or we can aggregate on
multiple dimensions then it becomes
clear this user has been only doing a
SPI flex a hundred dollars suddenly is
being at five thousand dollars one it's
risky MA discreetly catch on to that and
rules can also easily trigger that right
so this is the toy example of like what
do we mean by signaling like we have the
raw data we have the third-party data
that we get from like other sources and
so on we can augment this data with the
third-party data a great on any
dimensions that you want and then feed
into the next step of the pipeline right
so that's that's the signal engine that
that's where we will spend most of our
time in and how we build this robust
signal engine so let's look at the goals
of such system right so what should we
do for us given that the processes are
always changing behavior we cannot know
up front all the things that we would
want like for example
maybe they're all coming from satellites
at some point but they will change their
behavior maybe we cannot we can use the
ISP so we we don't know all the damages
we want to the agreed upon right at the
beginning so our class one should be
flexible enough that without writing any
new code we should be able to get these
aggregations the next thing is we don't
know what timeframes make sense for any
specific problem right so certain
businesses are seasonal so that
seasonality could be quarterly some
biggest are like yearly like say
somebody selling umbrellas in rainy
season that suspect you don't expect
them to sell sell bunch of formulas in
summer so we should be able to do here
over here month or Nia bank week or week
year-to-date month to take any kind of
aggregations and arbitrary time
dimensions easily again without adding
new code and then them these events are
happening between the users life cycle
or payment itself like payment has X
otherwise it is captured it is now
settled all those kinds of they're like
each of this users merchants payments go
through these on life cycles so they
generate events and each each of these
events will be ingested into our
pipelines and we want the Clayton sea to
be as small as possible if we leave
let's say a five minute or ten late
conductor gap fastest will just run
through that right so we don't want that
and the internal processing time should
be ideally in the order of like and X of
milliseconds and at most men for our
system we'd say that one second is the
maximum we could tolerate right and then
it should be easily scalable if the data
is too small we can do simple queries
and group bys and where clauses will get
all what you want but once the data
increases and you want the dynamic
nature the simple database kind of
schemes don't work we need a different
kind of solution and it needs to be
easily mental again like it's not be
DevOps heavy and so on so keeping those
goals in mind we thought of what is the
abstract data
pipeline that works for us we talked
about events getting generated right
there that's a streaming source and we
want them to go into some kind of
aggregation which is a black box and
stage we'll get into later like
describing what it is and we want it to
generate the partial aggregation not the
real aggregate but partial aggregates so
we can assemble them in run time to
decide what's the right time window with
the profit for us and then we should
have some kind of interface where users
can say like these the dimension I care
about this is the time unit I care about
and we get the responses back so being a
cloud native kind of a company not like
what's available at Google stack to
actually materialize this in real watery
Michelle can you help us understand what
are the contents available for us to
make this happen
sure Thank You Sean so before I get into
the details of the components available
on the Google cloud platform let's talk
a bit about the history of Google and
where it comes from
so Google started off to organize the
world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful and
for that Google build the search
application now the search application
obviously has a lot of very specific
components that are tuned in geared for
search but even with that there are a
number of generic big data problems that
Google has to solve to enable the search
application to run at the scale of the
Internet so for one we needed to be able
to store the large amounts of data that
would go into the search pipeline and we
needed to have different types of
storage systems depending on the type of
the content that we would be storing and
that might involve file systems
databases or other storage systems once
we have that data we need to be able to
process it and we need to be able to
build the search index from all that
content then may take the shape of
either batch processing in 472 build the
link wrap of the entire internet but we
also need to have real-time stream
processing to capture all the updates
happening in real time on web pages that
change every second every minute as
opposed to the things that stay constant
and Static for months and years at a
time and finally we need to be able to
serve this data and serve this content
and be able to upgrade our applications
such as the Search application live
without any downtime
a number of Google products have reached
over billion users so search Google Play
Chrome Android YouTube Maps Gmail and
Google cloud platform all serve each
over billion users using all the common
infrastructure and in fact all these
applications and all these services are
built on the same hardware the same
networking and also the same software
stack that powers all these individual
applications as well as available in the
Google cloud platform so let's walk it
through a couple examples of what are
the soft applications that make this
possible across a number of different
domains over the years Google has built
a number of technologies to support all
these various storage products or
service products starting with the
Google file system MapReduce BigTable
Dremel collapses spanner and others
Google has built a number of generic
systems from storage to processing to
machine learning as well as container
management to enable all these
applications to operating scale despite
their various differences in their
domain and now all these services are
available as part of Google cloud
platform grouped into various areas such
as compute storage databases big data
and machine learning and others so let's
walk through a couple examples of these
that maybe will be useful towards the
team that we pay so for one you know
look at the question those about you
know serving our users through the
search application so how would we run
container as workloads such that we can
upgrade and deploy and scale all our
applications very quickly and easily so
Google actually wrote the support for
containers and Linux and open source
that at C group what we also need is
something to orchestrate the services
and to be able to upgrade them so we
wrote borg and then we open source the
kubernetes container manager system and
now we provide a managed service around
kubernetes as google container engine
container engine provides color
management and orchestration it provides
a private container registry and it uses
declarative averies for specification
that will enforce for you at runtime it
also provides auto scaling to meet the
needs of applications
we also needed a file system that will
be able to scale to the size of the
internet as well as grow with the size
of the Internet and we needed to store
all the data from the growing Internet
as well as all the other applications
that users might generate so we first
build Google file system and then we
upgraded that with Colossus and today we
provide Google Cloud storage which is an
exabyte scale file system it has high
throughput it has replicated through
regional and multi-regional buckets it
has a uniform API across various storage
classes so you can either store cold
data warm data hot data and access them
uniformly through the same API so you
won't have to change your code to be
able to access the different types of
storage it also has an HDFS compatible
connector so you can use it from traduce
without changing your code at all once
we have all this data we need to be able
to process the data scale and as I
mentioned we need to be able to process
the data both in batch mode as well as
streaming mode over the years google has
written a number of different systems
such as MapReduce flume and mill-wheel
and we've combined all of those into
Google Cloud dataflow then what we did
was we open-source the SDK behind Google
Cloud dataflow as Apache beam Apache
beam recently became a top-level project
in Apache Software Foundation and you
can run code that reduces the Apache
beam SDK on top of other execution
engines besides the Google Cloud
dataflow you can also use it on sparking
linked data flow as I mentioned combine
both of the models both batch and
streaming so don't have to rewrite your
code to go from batch to streaming the
same exact code will work in both modes
so you have instant portability and you
can make the decision of how to deploy
the code and we'll see later how we they
uses that to their advantage their flow
provides auto scaling and dynamic task
charting so you don't have the problem
of the long stragglers taking a very
long time and flown down your overall
process when data flow notice is that
the tasks are taking too long it will
break up the tasks refine the work and
spin up at the additional workers if it
needs to to make sure that your jobs
complete quickly dataflow provides
connectors to various storage systems
such as BigTable the aquarian cloud
service you can read and write from
anywhere to anywhere and as I mentioned
it is portable with
beam SDK so we also needed a way to run
open source processing engines such as
could open spark and so for that we
wrote and provide Google Cloud data
products data product provides Hadoop
spark pig hive and other Big Data
components it also provides connectors
to BigTable the query and cloud storage
what this allows you to do is that you
can run stateless could do pin spark
clusters this means that you can bring
them up very quickly and turn them down
when you need to when you don't need to
use them because you're using BigTable
cloud storage and Victoria's hosted
storage solutions this also allows you
to do something very different it allows
you to think about your processing as
job rather than think about long live
clusters so rather than saying I need to
run across training to maintain a
cluster you can just submit jobs using
the cloud data for KPI and it will make
those clusters appear it will grow them
and you can then turn them down in
addition to the batch storage we also
needed very fast storage at petabyte
scale so what happened specifically with
search is that some pages as I mentioned
get updated very very quickly while
others take days or weeks or months to
be updated if we always build our
indexes in batch flow by rewriting large
index files we'll always be behind and
will we have very stale search index so
what we needed was a database that
scales to the petabytes that gave us
random access to every single data item
in the database very very quickly and so
for that with built ik table and now
that's available at Google cloud pick
tables part of Google cloud platform and
I'll go into a bit more detail about
what is BigTable how it works and what
it makes possible so BigTable is a no
sequel database it's a fully managed
service it provides set up I'd scale and
storage with low latency access to any
item in the database it provides
seamless scalability for throughput and
it learns and adjusts to the access
pattern let's do a deep dive into the
last two points so the big table schema
is it provides a sparse no sequel white
column database what this means is that
if you're not storing data in some of
the cells that does not count against
the storage BigTable provides a single
index which is a rope
so roki design is very important when
using BigTable and it provides atomic
single road transactions across all the
columns the best way to think about
BigTable is as a three dimensional
spreadsheet there are rows columns and
every cell has timestamp version now
those versions are in 54 so you can
consider them as time you can also use
them as arbitrary version IDs so each of
those intersections there can have
multiple versions at a high level
clients connect to a single endpoint
which then dispatches the request to the
various BigTable nodes in the next
couple slides I'm going to remove the
load balancing a proxy layer for
simplicity to show the actual
connections and how they will be
forwarded from the client to the
processing nodes but always remember
that there's that low prot load
balancing proxy layer so that clients
don't actually have to have a discovery
service to find out which nodes they
need to connect to and win so one
interesting thing about BigTable is that
BigTable even though it's a database is
actually a stateless system so BigTable
doesn't actually store any data all the
data that is stored in BigTable is
actually stored one Colossus are
distributed file system this is actually
true for all other Google storage
systems this is something that BigTable
spanner and victory all share so let's
say we have a particular BigTable node
that is managing a bunch of data on
Colossus and all of a sudden the data
that it's managing is the currently
popular with the clients and so they
keep all accessing it so now that note
is getting more activity and more
requests than other nearby nodes
BigTable will notice this and
automatically rebalance the data such
that the load will then spread to other
nodes and it will even the low
distribution on the classroom
this happens transparently the clients
are not aware of this as I mentioned
earlier they go through a little
balancing layer that proxies these
requests through the different notes now
what happens here is that the data
doesn't actually move from a BigTable
node without a big stable node the data
stays continuously in the Colossus
filesystem all that happens is that
we're refining metadata
assignment of the data from one node to
another so this is actually a very fast
operation it does not take size of data
it takes seconds or less what this also
allows us to do is that it takes it
allows us to scale the cluster both up
and down to provide more throughput to
the data because reassignment is really
really quick what this means is that we
can add more and more nodes to the
cluster and they will share and split
the responsibility for the data
management in Colossus and it will be
seamless again the clients will not
notice they will just propagate higher
throughput to the underlying data what
this does provide us then is because the
noes are able to quickly reassign and
manage data separately and the nodes
don't communicate with each other there
is a background process behind the
scenes which is a big table master node
which manages the assignments this
provides us with linear scalability in
throughput to big tables so whether you
have three nodes in your cluster 30 or
300 the processing power is directly
proportional to the number of nodes and
so this allows for linear scalability
and performance mini storage system sent
flattened out and then limit the
scalability as the cluster size grows
not so a big table in March of last year
we presented a use case where a customer
used 3,500 BigTable nodes with 200 data
flow workers of 32 cores each and it
also scales when your lay at that scale
and we've tested it with larger clusters
beyond that as well and at this point I
would like to turn it over to way from
week a to continue the conversation
about what they use yes thanks Misha hi
everybody my name is Wei Lee I'm the
engineer leading the data aggregation
pipeline at a BP so in this section of
my talk I'm going to go some technical
textiles into how we set up the data
pipeline and the challenges that we are
facing and the the architecture this
hinted ma made and also show the
problems that we deploy to production
and at the end they are shared with you
what we key takeaways from
imitation so let's come back to the
technical goals so when we start we want
to create a data plan is that you can
aggregate on any dimension and the
caning also the province or arbitrary
time windows so these are the feature
requests actually we are going to go
into more detail when we're doing the
implementation and the next three is
about the end to end the processing time
less than one second so this is more
like a performance and we did some
upfront testing and we are going to do
more in the architecture analysis as
well and the last two requirement is why
is the easy scaling because we are
facing the issue that we are having
ran out the old databases and cannot
hold up a traffic and easy maintain it
so these are crucial for us to go to a
large-scale production but engineer wise
is actually pretty challenging because
when we are talking about easy scaling
means that we want systems which can go
up really as the same time that are
trapping is growing so and the easy
maintainability the anybody has the
exchange with the data paralyze dead
half we know that probably it would
involve like a bash and streaming which
is really hard to maintain so those are
hard technical questions and rebate
which is actually a start-up we actually
bound by the resource but our business
is growing so we want to get the system
ready fast so that's where the Google
coming to picture because they have lots
of good stuff like a abroad this slide
from dish'
like a different aspects for the
computation so we are going to look
introduces choice and the combine we saw
like we pay a set up to see what we can
do to set up and create converting the
abstract pipeline to a more concrete
implementation so here's the slides that
we have earlier for the or abstract
architecture for real-time pipeline
so potentially we have four components
the extremists source aggregation engine
and a great Apache aggregation storage
and then the customer qgi
so in this Lego component by component
to see why we make what decision we made
and the which component we take to use
so first off the streaming source so we
actually look at the two different
components Apache Kafka and the cloud
pops up we started with the cloud
pub/sub we did the performance analysis
which we proved in well but we pay is
actually using a lot of Apache Kafka
inside our system over a technology
stack and this is widely available so
given that the two components have seen
the functional features but we pay is
the ecosystems more inclined to the
Apache Kafka so that's why we eventually
end up using the Apache Kafka and so the
final outcomes that we actually hosting
the Apache Kafka using the compute
engine inside Google Cloud the next
component comes in and is the
aggregation engine so the component we
look at is the cloud dataflow so like
there are lots of good stuff from the
gate flow features which is supports the
easy support the data transformation and
more in friendís has a unified model to
propose streaming and a batch processing
so which is actually really important
first when we think about this
architecture when we're trying to make
it more operational and also another
advantage is it have handles the event
time processing so which means is that
we actually can get determining the
behavior
every time we process the event and also
this strong exactly one semantics it's
really important for us to get to don't
duplicant the events but what most
importantly is that this is actually
unmanaged
it is skillful horizontally so
increasing our technicals that we can
scale well so that's actually our
technical choice to use the de Flores
the aggregation engine the electric
component we have is the partial
aggregation storage so the component we
look at is the club BigTable as Wendy
she already said is proving to the
handle petabyte data scale use case and
also has very low latency in both in
terms of both read and write and the
reality of integration is data flow so
it's a big table IO is there and for our
business questions if we want to time
serious Chris we have a proper schema
design ETL kind of the rig aware and
also most important is that it is also
managing service it can scarce words on
tree so the last component that we are
looking at is the customer curate UI so
this is actually our business logic so
what will the ended up is to decided on
the bidding arrested Java service
running use new taco containers the goal
of this recipe is just acting as the
create proxy for difficut able to embody
our query logic for example the customer
speaking logic to answer different
custom interval questions and giving
that the services of stages we can
actually scale really easily just by
pumping up the replication to multiple
instances so with all these
considerations this comes down to our
concrete architecture for real-time
pipeline so as you can see in the graph
in the diagram here we cracked
we actually instrumental application
code and collected events when the event
happening and the pump into the upper
cheek Africa and has a Kalka IO
streaming events to the data data flow
process engine and then with the Asha
aggregation which are theoretically
outputting in the big table and again we
have accurate service to create that to
answer business questions for the data
consumers to use
so the next step comes to is the
authenticity if we want to get this in
production right so in production a
failure is always happening we need to
be able to handle them and the be
resilient and people you only use one
single stream pipeline it's not probably
enough so the natural thinking is to
come to a mixed streaming on the batch
and this actually fits really well with
the data flow that's why our original
thought of why we use this one is that
they have a unified processing model for
both the challenge process is that a cop
car all by default is streaming i/o so
if we want to set up a batch we need to
do some customization on this one so the
good thing about us is that our event is
actually all done based so for all the
events which we actually mandatory to
have a custom event I mean happened so
that's what that's the base was to
create a bounded kafka i/o so looking at
this example this is an example is a
assume that we have six events coming
and all the green ones are coming in the
same hour and we have some out of all
the event comes in and the wind in the
production in our deployment we actually
have a whole batch job which actually
aggregates in the outer interval so for
that particular case the our customers
wanted cup guy or what it does is it
will take the range for the outlet that
is interested to aggregate and the
greaser or the cup event up to now and
only output the event following this you
put the you're interested range so by
doing this we essentially achieve the
batch processing and with this last
problem solved we actually go to the
full-fledged production deployment with
all the kinds of variations so as you
can see this diagram is that in the
century is still 1/9 we have a streaming
processing processing and the curry but
we have different flavors of pipeline
processing on top is the real-time
which actually consisting listen to the
Africa events and persistent period to
the epic table in the finest granary I
think for us is using minutes and also
for different granularity we have the
our badge daily badge and other that so
given that we have the customer bonded
on the cuff I all set up so they just
take the events and we just deploy one
event is using one single codebase and
it's really easy for us to minting and
the manage so then with this
reproduction sized we can come back to
visit all technical goals I go about the
first to use the elastic we have talked
about why we make the decision so the
first to use for example wines that we
wanted to a dynamic aggregation or any
dimensions using our aggregation engine
so the foot actually the history the
first iteration for us is that we are
thinking just okay every time we want a
new aggregation we just start up a new
customer data pipeline remember they're
doing customized transformation and
doing aggregation is actually turned out
to not be very flexible because if you
want to add one new metrics a new
aggregation you want to deploy a new
pipeline that's too hard right
operational it's not feasible so what we
end up is actually create a new
transformation is very simple so the
Nordics tab is kind of Nina so for the
first tab we just read all the events
coming and we just the larger window by
different custom event time and then
group by the customer dimension and the
aggregate and means inside same group
and output appear racket into the big
table so on the right as you can see
this production example not that is this
is actually testing case example so this
is just one linear transformation of the
back of a dataflow pipeline and what's
flexible about this is that we actually
make the schema kind of flexible so for
example we have four raquel text for
every schema so first line is the
timestamp
this isn't mandatory so every event have
a time that's debate for us to play by
the runtime and also have a customized
the dimension that you can provide your
own dimension by feeling this is a tag
and also we suppose customer types like
a numeric which is for numeric attacker
will collect like what's mean minimal
what's the average or a maximum and
total and the county structure so it's
kind of additional aggregation on this
one also categorical so we're going to
give you back the like a unique values
count for this particular window
dimension and also the geolocation
essentially is that in this particular
window what's DQ span of the events
happening so this is got customer types
we provided and for the value field is
just theorized form of the graduated we
can custom a combiner we are consumed
and I generate this is a look at one
example how we make this more make this
work so when event we are seeing is the
freedom per user
let's uses a fake event so this is a
super ABC store which he received a 100
dollar payment originally Bravo City CA
n + 4 0 6 3 on the Penn State March the
1st so the highlight phase are actually
rather than different attributes of this
events so one immense we can extract
from this wines the payment amount right
so we can generate events for this is a
like a at this time the dimension on
payment amount we create an America
metric which is $100 and of the
allegation pipeline would we pick regard
the result we can also the question like
what are the total process the premium
amount you're seeing under how about
average amount and the standard
deviation in the sector so by doing this
this can doing the up loma detection
from the same event we can also generate
another metric which is like a free
Nevada criminal occasion then we can
just easily change it type code Ichiro
location and give you the value and with
this we can say what's the code
shushing of your payment put particular
merchant so by combining these two we
have a simple tax which means that we
have a very stable pipeline and we have
a flex or schema which means that we can
dynamically adjust adding any
aggregations so if you're interested for
another election set it is for us to
change their patterns and if we see any
new aggregation we are interested which
is the pumping different things so when
we combine these two together just we
got a very stable and the still very
flexible solution where can support our
fastest racing on the aggression on
different dimensions so the next text
your challenges was to come down to the
time series curious so our one thing we
leveraged from pick table is use the
rocket design so we set up the ways the
rock is that the time stamp is always
the first step a part of the arrow key
so essentially if we are interested in
particular time range you can filter by
the prefix and get results back and also
for performance optimization we actually
create a different columns I mean is for
different granularity for example in the
example here where minutes hour day and
week and so then when we try to answer
the question for your customer time
interval so one like a knife solutions
that we just go to the every minute and
combine them together so in the example
here if we want to aggregate between per
buried eternity to March the 8th if we
go by minister-level is too many right
it's not organized given that we have
defined greedy
aggression already so we actually
implement this intense teaching in the
sense that we can get the value spawned
a lot larger screen area first and then
stun to the next level and so on so we
can get all the values but we can reduce
the load to the big table
I'm sure the key table can handle this
but we just don't want to overload it
so the next detector go is the
performance I maintain dignity so we
have been able to deploy the pipeline
into production and for several months
and it's actually performed pretty well
and the computer all system it's also
very stable and fast and in a summary is
that the key takeaway was is that Google
Cloud managed service actually showed us
from those heavy lifting technical
challenges such as getting out and the
dynami resource managing in structure we
can actually move to more energy and
focus on the business problems that's
imperium out the infrastructure so and
also inside we pay we are using lots of
components provided by Google cloud
platform like such as bigquery absorb
datastore that we have a pretty good
post only to at the V code vk.com
so if you're interested you can check it
out and the last I would like to really
thank the Google cloud team both
BigTable or Club dataflow April and the
support the doing the process has
blossomed injection with various things
and they're really helpful and they help
us get to the pipelines up and running
and that's not least and also electives
and all the team members from VP this is
not just one project by development is
actually joined between the operational
and the development because if you're
manage type lines really hard and we are
both things are we working really
closely to make this happen
so we sister hand over the Mac to
robbing for outbound thanks
Oh
hi everyone my name is Robin and I'm the
lead engineer outbound today I will be
talking to you guys about on demand
scaling with big table to achieve low
lengthy and high throughput so first we
started about four years ago and
currently we process about 40 million
vents and off of that 1 million messages
are sent per day we started with a very
simple question
what you could create and manage any
kind of message without engineering help
going off of that what you could measure
the quality of each message by seeing
what users do after they receive it when
I mean any kind of message I truly mean
anytime outbound supports email SMS
mobile web push and even web hooks for
advanced use cases that we have not
covered yet after you send a message
it's no there's much more to it than
crew open the message or who clicked a
link it's more about the users journey
what did they do inside of your app
after they received a message for
instance this external reducing trip
actually lead to less churn our pal
allows you to do three things first
decide who you should message by
segmentation on user actions and
attributes second help you convey your
message with a powerful editor and
multi-channel support and third looking
at the report page and see which variant
is doing better or work and adjust the
relocation allocations so here's an
example of our segmentation in process
first we want to message users living in
San Francisco or Palo Alto or Mountain
View and we want to message those who
have given us their phone numbers so the
phone number exists in our database
third we want to message those who are
on a trial so account type is equal to
trial our filters are boolean
expressions and we allow users to chain
on and and ORS here your 8
to take the type of channel you want to
message on and you're not sure you're
also able to create more variants in the
AP test on different channels say for
example you want to test on mobile
versus the web push once you have to
once I'll pick the channel and populated
a message content you're able to define
any goals that you want outbound to
track so in this example we want users
to read more blog posts within one day
of receiving this message and we want
users to make more orders within three
days of receiving this message here
you're able to see a reporting page
summarizing three things 1 number of
unique metric users touched by this
campaign 2 different variant statistics
including control groups and 3 any goals
you may have set up on our back end we
see about two to four thousand events
per second and it grows 10 percent
month-over-month our peak to baseline
ratio is four to ten because we have
customers internationally so to be able
to sustain this type of usage pattern we
either need to over provision or set up
auto scaling also per API call the
workload variance has is very high it
could range from background users
history to triggering campaigns and
goals now let's look at a diagram of our
back-end infrastructure so when an API
call comes in it hits our load balancer
then it spins off to one of our servers
that does minimal validation such
validations can include the subtract
call having events on it and deserve a
user ID attached and whether the API key
is valid or not once it has been
validated its Brendan gets put in what
to one of our various cues and workers
pull items off of various cues when
market has come in they usually have a
goal that they want to lift in they
would typically type their event stream
into analytics products such as Mixpanel
or Google Analytics then also those
analytics products they will try to
generate predictive indicators what
those indicators in hand they will run
tests to validate it and tune wherever
it's necessary
this process is often very lengthy and
requires a lot of engineering help and
support our bond is now able to improve
this process by generating ideas for the
marketer using their own accounts event
stream the marketer now only needs to
approve the suggestion and can then go
on to write the content without being
blocked by engineering so this is an
example of a model for a video
subscription company the goal here is to
add more subscription so the insight is
users who verify email and then don't
read an article within a day are less
likely to add subscription based on this
insight the marketers can can target
those users by recommending them
articles when they verify the email the
ability to generate these insights is
where BigTable shines currently we have
over 12 billion events and over 200
million end-users the algorithm to run
this job is very joint and very shuffle
heavy however we're now able to get this
down in under three hours
traditionally without BigTable this
process would typically expect from the
database perform some sort each Al
transformation then store into a data
warehouse so that it doesn't affect
production traffic then perform more
details and once satisfied we would then
put it back in its database this process
is again often very lengthy and requires
VBA provisioning with BigTable it
replaces all this as we need more
throughput we'll just make an API call
to increase capacity as Misha has
previously mentioned make table
throughput scales linearly so as we
increase increased nodes from X to Y the
support QPS also goes from A to B
once our big table instance has been
increased we are now able to run spark
with data cloud proc over once the job
finishes we can then scale BigTable down
another way that we use BigTable is in
our compute process so our back-end
infrastructure follows a
service-oriented architecture
implementing synchronous queues and with
an API called that can vary in the
workload queue backups occasionally
happen so we implemented our own
autoscaler
it runs off of Jenkins and watches over
data guard it also scales off of queue
depth and CPU utilization alongside with
other smaller factors what the number of
machines is required it will either
spin-up or spin-down BigTable nodes to
ensure that readwrite Lane P is low
previously you would have to read
partition and add machines manually to
achieve capacity and often over times
often times over provisioning is the
right answer however this leads to a
higher compute cost and we're now able
to add and remove capacity with just one
API call in the corner there you can see
an example of our autoscaler piping the
data into slack products like clouds
BigTable are one of the reasons why
startups are able to be able to
accomplish so much with such a small
team these products create a massive
leverage on the people on your team I
would like to pass it off Commissioner
I would like to thank you very much for
speaking so Robin way and Shawn this is
how you can see how the scalable product
that Google cloud platform offers that
it built for Google and Google services
are able to be leveraged by companies to
solve their own Big Data problem so
these generic tools that we built to
solve our specific problems are now
possible to solve any other problem as
well as in other domains
[Music]
[Music]